okay today I'm going to talk to you
about states of matter there's three
different states of matter solids
liquids and gases I'm going to show you
that the similarities and differences
between all three states of matter so
we're going to start off by looking at
solids so what I'm doing right now is
I'm drawing the particles in a solid I'm
representing the particles just by these
little circles so as you can see in a
solid the particles are closely packed
together in this kind of formation this
kind of formation is called a lattice
that's the just the name for this kind
of shape that's repeating units tightly
packed together so as you can see there
are very strong forces of attraction
between each different particle that's
what holds them in this fixed shape so
they do have a definite shape that they
hold they also have a fixed volume which
means the volume is consistent it's
fixed next up there is let the particles
have low energy there's a low amount of
energy in each of the particles also
they're not free to move so they're not
free to move anyway so this particle
couldn't just start moving off over here
but they do vibrate so each of these
each of these particles can vibrate now
the more you heat up these particles the
more that they vibrate that's what
causes objects to expand when they're
heated okay next up we have liquids so
again I'm going to draw the particle
model to show what's going on in liquids
so as you can see they're not in that
kind of uniform shape as before no of
men see I know I haven't done this
perfectly but these circles are meant to
be in the same size because just if a
substance melted for example these these
particles wouldn't change size I just
haven't drawn it perfectly
so there are some forces between the the
different particles but much weaker than
the forces between the particles and
solids different to solids they are free
to move because the solids had a
definite shape they were all kind of in
fixed positions it's different in
liquids these particles move freely they
feel they they become the shape of any
container that they are put in so if you
put a liquid in a container they fill
and become the shape of that container
now compared with solids they have the
part individual particles have more
energy so each particle for example this
particle here would have more paths more
energy than this particle here if it was
the same substance so they have more
energy each particle Vande the energy of
each particle in solids also they have
random movements so these particles move
randomly all the way around so they're
all moving randomly and in motion
whereas these ones remember their fixed
positions they only vibrate so the third
state of matter is gases now as you can
see from this particle diagram the
particles in gases are really really
spread out so there's very or virtually
virtually no forces between the
different particles very very low forces
between the particles very weak forces
between the particles just like in
liquids the particles are free to move
so it's only solids where the particles
are in fixed positions and gases the
particles are free to move now not only
do they fill the shape of the bottom of
any container gases fill the container
so they completely fill any container
that they are put into now out of the
three the particles in the solids let's
say this is the same substance the
particles in the solid has the lowest
energy the particles in the liquid
more energy the particles in a gas have
to have the most energy so each particle
is much more energetic than either
solids or liquids and finally just like
just like in liquids we have random
motion or random movement so these
particles are moving around in random
directions so that is the difference
between the three states of matter
solids liquids and gases
thank you